He's a very energetic kid, that's amazing. He's
chewing, but it's okay. What should we name him?
No, I don't know what to name him. He's got a white square pattern on his brown back. Well, he's toast. He's not cute. Yeah, well, his name is cute.  What are you going to do with
that child?
Even if you try to find a foster parent, you won't be able to find one for a while, so I guess there's nothing you can do about it. I'm worried about
leaving you with Ginga and the others, and you'll
have to take care of him for 23 months due to retesting for the virus.
If you can't
find a foster parent, Toast will be home.
[Music] I
don't have the confidence to buy it when it's time to buy it. Yes, it looks like
he's doing well. That's a
relief. It's best that he's doing well. I'll
keep him at home for the time being, so I'm going to go buy some things right now.
Seriously?  If you'd like to thank me,
please leave the procurement to me. All I ask of my gate is white powder. I'll get you
anything from high to high. Please be
careful. I won't just
look over at you. It's
not appropriate.
Ginga-kun,
cat litter.  Don't be afraid to force it, but be
careful about products made with scientific ingredients.
Even if they are naturally derived, you can't use products that contain preservatives, deodorants, or
synthetic products. It's
rice, but it's edible by humans.  It's a
must to
use something that's safe to eat. Don't use oatmeal with unknown ingredients.
Also, cheap ones may contain grains that cats can't digest, so
avoid them as much as possible and wait for a while.
Anyway, it's healthy for your pet.  It takes a certain amount of
knowledge, effort, and money to maintain your health, so I did my
best to find one.
[Music] Your
husband also knows a lot about cats. Humans
can manage their own health, but pets ca
n't do that.
Pets  The health of Nasu is the responsibility of the owner, so we need to
take good care of him. I'm
sure Nasu's pet will be happy. I'm sorry to have kept you
waiting, but there was nothing particularly bad about him. Good, he didn't get
violent. It's ok, he's eating.  You've
become very quiet. Thank you.
You're
healthy.
[Music]
Cute and cute are even
cuter. So let's go home. Starting tonight,
Toast is our family.
Why?